alors que les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes au sujet de la qu'ovide et que
certains évoquent la possibilité d'un
troisième confinement tout le monde ne
sont pas prêts à suivre sagement cette
nouvelle injonction et appelle même à la
désobéissance
ça fait déjà un an que ça dure là ça
suffit c'est le cas par exemple de
didier maïsto ancien patron de sud radio
qui contestent l'efficacité de ces
mesures qu'ils jugent liberticide
personne n'a fait la preuve de
l'efficacité des couvre feux pour lui
même si le gouvernement appelle les
français à se re confiné il n'est pas
question de bénir
quoi qu'il arrive je ne me reconcile ça
veut dire vous mettra hors la loi je me
mettrais hors-la-loi je l'assumerai je
ferai ma vie un comportement qui
pourrait poser problème au gouvernement
s'il se généralise
alors comprenez vous la volonté de
désobéir en cas de troisième confinement
dj stoxx est avec nous ancien patron de
sud radio
merci didier d'être là alors vos
qualités votre notre position de
position de geste citoyen ou d'actes de
rébellion
ce qui a beaucoup de gens tony sur
l'acte de rébellion peut pas faire ça je
qualifierais sa de de bon sens on a un
petit peu de recul aujourd'hui il faut
être extrêmement modeste face à ce virus
jacques admirable il ya beaucoup de
stratégies qui ont été utilisés l'an
dans différentes et dans différents pays
rien n'a vraiment fonctionné en a qui
ont confiné strictement donc d'autres
qui ont laissé complètement ouvert alors
il ya les pays où south à ponctionner à
quelques qui s'en sortent un
quelques-uns s'appelle encore rire
confident qu'en matière et enveloppes et
englobe alors que jusqu'à présent on a
un petit peu de recul aujourd'hui on a
presque un an avec ce virus de pratiquer
la première fois ok premier confinement
se dit on connaît pas on découvre tout
le monde a fait contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur à jouer le jeu s'est confiné
on était dans l'inconnu on était dans
l'inconnu et puis on avait on a eu
beaucoup plus peur je trouve de de la
maladie moi je me rappelle un canton
recevait des courses on savait pas si
pas l'élégance avec sa fille avait
vraiment utilisée qu' on savait pas
qu'elle était les portées de la maladie
donc on vivait vraiment dans une
angoisse paul voilà ce qui ce qui mine
de rien inquiétant c'est que on a
l'impression qu'on vit normalement mais
encore confiné c'est-à-dire un corps
confie n'est pas complètement
normalement mais on al'impression de 10
normalement et c'est ça qui est grave
trouble parce que on oublie peut-être
certains gestes barrières
ces termes et vous pour vous le
confinement eux vous dit c'est quoi ça
sert à rien écoutez on a du recul
aujourd'hui on a confiné on a des
consignes et on a ouvert grand les
vannes le président la république lui a
dit il a montré l'exemple on était en
vacances mais didier juste de quoi vous
dire on a confiné pourquoi parce qu'en
fait pourquoi on confine à chaque fois
c'est pour éviter les embouteillages on
vit au zoo tirs dont un en l'aidant dans
les réanimations de cet assaut perdu on
peut pas voir on n'a pas assez de lits
pour les ranimer ce sacre est important
c'est le premier poème haye depuis 1993
songez qu'il ya eu 103 mini qui ont été
supprimés en france
champion du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires mais on dépense des sommes
folles pour la santé donc on a beaucoup
de sous couche administrative
on a essayé kiki tampon sur plus pour la
santé est pour et pour les animer didier
a aujourd'hui oublié de vous parler 93
aujourd'hui en vrai on se dit tout ça a
été mal fait ou bien on se dit on avance
et on essaie de bien on essaie d'avancer
il ya des solutions
oui alors confinement on n'a pas fait la
preuve que ça fonctionnait s'il est ce
que cette fois à la sas a fait
redescendre le noyau aujourd'hui c'est
le cnrd
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire ceux
là bas si tous les pays dans tous les
pays qui ont confiné
on voit qu'il ya une baisse des cas sion
une baisse des personnes en réanimation
donc une baisse des décès il ya la
saisonnalité qui joue premièrement il ya
on sait qu'on ne connaît rien
pour ce virus est ce que vous êtes
spécialiste pas non mais non mais vous
vous avez donc commencé en disant que je
n'aurais pas spécialiste élèves
devraient répondre je vais à la
saisonnalité c'est d'aller au bout de
l'allée gigounon raisonnement allégé dit
parce que le procès en
finir est ce que si le confinement
avaient marché est ce qu'on se serait
confinée oui ou non
bah oui première question quand ça
marche donc comme le confirme en marche
ce qui a marché pour la recommandation
ont donc comme ça ma au jour
d'aujourd'hui rares parents seront
confirmées aujourd'hui denis plein de
choses la fille choquée tout va bien
dans mes cordes à dire je la seule chose
pour l'instant qu'ils font c'est d'une
logique assez bon c'est du lot je sais
c'est dauphiné pour ça marche tellement
bien que mais en chine ça fonctionne ça
marche tellement bien combat sans arrêt
sera confiée alors non à la zone euro
devaient attendre des treks deux petites
minutes après que ce sujet didier je me
suis allé d'abord on le laisse en laisse
développer ses idées et après vous
pourrez lui répondre pour l'instant on
va laisser développer ses idées on passe
à la dernière bougie google consiste à
dire merci à les mondes il a quoi si la
logique consiste à dire vous plaît que
le confinement marche tellement que
chaque fois on fait des stop and go et
corps confie oui c'est d'une logique
irréfutables je vous laisse la
responsabilité de cette logique bon le
couvre-feu
le couvre-feu on parle on verra demain
les ce qui sera annoncé de le ramener à
18 heures peut-être sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et ça veut dire qu'on va quitter nos
boulots à 16 heures avec on va aller
chercher des gamins à l'école et qu'on
va tous se concentrer dans les
supermarchés il y aura plus de gestes
barrières ça sera dans le stress ça sera
dans la panique
ça sera dans l'urgence est de retour du
mans mais c'est la réalité c'est pas un
sentier dont vous vous adore mais donc
vous vous dites je vais pas respecté le
couvre-feu moi je vais sortir après 18
heures enfin moi j'en dis simplement il
ya des mesures qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre qui sont un respect strict des
mesures sanitaires des protocoles
sanitaires aujourd'hui ici on est tous
ensemble on échangera du plexiglas mode
c'est ce que j'avais fait à la radio etc
j'ai jamais reçu de radio 2,4 cole vide
et c'est bon on se lave les mains on a
des deux on respecte les dix tentes sont
fait pas n'importe quoi
on a on a des matches qu'on a des
comportements raisonnable on va pas
faire la fête à aller voir nos parents
âgés moi j'ai des parents très âgées et
je suis privé de les voir je suis pas
annie responsable je dis simplement ce
qui marche aujourd'hui ce sont des
mesures sanitaires strictes et de la
responsabilité personnelle
il n'y a jamais eu de contamination donc
très peu dans les entreprises n'a pas eu
donc que je sache dans les salles de
spectacles et dans l'est par dessiner
et les théâtres il y en a pas eu dans
les dents les dans les commerces
indépendants les métro les transports en
commun sont bondées les hypermarchés
sont bondés il ya deux poids deux
mesures hélas un moment je voudrais
simplement qu'on m'explique quel est la
logique de cette vie à 100 à l'heure où
tout le monde prend le métro on est là
les uns sur les autres on va sur ses
seins
bon c'est un discours qu'on entend du
patois mais j'en entendu à didier vous
aller plus loin vous voulez le réel ou
si c'est le cas de confinement didier
vous appelait à la rébellion et vous dit
attacher de ce nom c'est on va on va
voir ce que vous avez dit alors voilà
j'ai dit qu'à titre personnel je le
reste ne nous a pas d'accord alors
allez-y regarde dans les entreprises il
ya très peu de contamination dans les
théâtres dans les cinémas on en a vu
aucune dans les commerces indépendants
alors qu'on peut aller je le rappelle
dans les hypermarchés qui sont bondés et
les transports en commun qui sont bondés
jour après jour il ya quand même deux
poids deux mesures et cela manque de bon
sens de ma question trouve donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait ce tweet
quoi qu'il arrive je ne me reconsidère
ça veut dire vous mettra hors la loi je
me mettrais hors-la-loi je l'assumerai
je ferai ma vie et en les masquant
faisant tout bien mais on en nuances en
refusant d'être en fermer alors dit de
ce que vous avez dit chez jean marc
morandini donc vous pouvez leur dire
aujourd'hui vous allez vous allez sortir
vous écoutez c'est très simple je vais
voulu prendre je vais sortir et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi ce qu'il faut
pas simplement faire le buzz
il faut regarder toujours les documents
c'est ça lors du 2ème confinement moi
j'ai lu tous les jours les documents
officiels et les communiqués de presse
ils sont assez rébarbatif mais il faut
les lire de santé publique je pense qu
est-ce qui disait il disait que aux
premiers froids quand les gens se sont
re confinés chez eux
les premiers transports en commun il
travaillait son sont confinés chez eux
qui ont été les clusters ou honte et les
foyers de copies de contamination dans
les familles
parce que dès qu'il fait froid dès que
l'hiver arrive on est dans les familles
on se confine alors que la journée on
vaque à ses occupations
c'est ça la vérité donc premièrement
deuxièmement j'ai pas envie je fais
beaucoup de reportages dans la france
profonde comme on dit je vois des
étudiants qui sont au bord du suicide ce
à en parler dans ces incidents
je vois des restaurateurs je vois des
commerçants je vois des gens qui
exemple qui sont à bout de forces qui
sont à bout de nerfs qu'à l'horizon on
leur propose autre effet collatéral
je parle avec beaucoup de médecins comme
sans doute beaucoup d'entre vous tous
les toutes les autres pathologies les
cancers qu'on arrivait à détecter et
c'est on le fait plus aujourd'hui où il
ya des nouveaux des cancer en phase
terminale
c'est un vrai scandale les désastres
psychologiques la détresse des gens on
est en train d'être complètement
zombifiés mis sous cloche
est ce qu'on a envie de ça pour notre
avenir je finis là dessus un autre effet
collatéral la violence faite aux femmes
les viols qui ont explosé bien sûr les
violences familiales
mais didier est qu'est ce qu'on fait on
va faire des misères à dire ans confie
longtemps mais vous avez une remed et
vous savez que j'étais un grand vous
êtes un grand patron de média où elle
était là pour vous vous comprenez bien
que les gens ce qui vous reprochent moi
je me fais le porte parole de ce que je
vois sur les réseaux quand vous appelez
à la rébellion l'a plein de gens qui
lisent
vous avez une voix qui porte vous avez
un discours qui intéresse beaucoup de
monde et qui peut influencer beaucoup de
monde quand vous appelez à dire aux gens
quand vous arrêtez le confinement il ya
plein de gens qui vont dire pas pourquoi
didier maïsto lf et puis savait et donc
ils les jurats mentir je suis les gens
n'ont pas besoin de moi mais ça
normalement
j'ai simplement objective pourra vous le
faites alors vous mais parce que j'ai
eus objective et un ressenti très
profond très répandu dans la société
française nicolas pernikoff vous n'avez
pas l'air d'accord avec hp tous d'accord
alors j'aime beaucoup didier parce qu'il
ya des combats je respecte que vous
menez et gégé respecte là je vous
comprends pas je vous le dit soit vous
êtes en campagne politique parce que ce
que vous êtes en train d'essayer de ne
vous êtes même pas en train de dire
parce que je vous écouterai si vous
dites je dénonce toutes les incohérences
et gad elmaleh faisait a dit des choses
d'ailleurs sur les avions il a raison ce
raid international ion qu'on aura les
incohérences rien à comprendre les
connais tout les jour d'hui le seul
moyen
le seul moyen de freiner cette épidémie
c'est le fameux stop and go dont vous
parlez c'est à dire qu'on sait bien que
lui réduit y avoir un travail de l'état
je pense sur le fait d'augmenter les lie
parce que on est toujours à cinq ou six
mille lits de réanimation
on devrait en avoir dix huit ou vingt
mille aujourd'hui donc on ne l'a pas
anticipé je suis aussi d'accord avec
vous mais aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
l'homme que vous êtes ne peut pas
appeler alors à désobéir et ses
obligations sein c'est une option
comme aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je termine
tous les emplois aujourd'hui les plus
grands que sont out ou d'autres je suis
désolé moi je respecte
raul qui est un grand acquis le réanimer
en tout cas c'est un grand monsieur
on serait à 200 ou 300 mille morts ou
d'autres si on dit qu'on n'avait pas
confiné exactement ça aujourd'hui lui
même est en train et même un accident
mailleront à 10400 mis le mot japonais
d'alors un million on n'en sait rien et
la solution sais rien mais je voulais
passer plateau vous êtes vous êtes
quelqu'un d'autre que ça même pas se
baigner sur un plateau pour proposer une
solution alors vous l'importez alors je
alors la solution je vous l'apprends pas
de solution c'est quoi la solution
le remède là pour l'instant est pire que
le mal parce que sur didier je devrais
je dire un truc avant que vous proposez
votre solution
vous avez vu que dans le monde entier on
trouve pas la solution donc là vous avez
là le monde entier nous regarde
la solution c'est maintien jg il faut
toujours
alors puisqu'on parle de médecine les
médecins vous diront tous et le
professeur out avec qui on a souvent
échangé il faut soigner il faut faire le
ratio bénéfice risque au bout d'un an
quand le ratio bénéfice risque penche
plus du côté du risque on a le droit
elle saurait expliquer pose est ce que
vous dites là donc il faut la vente il
ya une balance
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
là parce que ce que vous êtes en train
de dire didier si je comprends bien
si vous dites le risque de mort il est
déjà de et les voilà il y les deux sens
est-ce qu'on va prendre
est-ce qu'on va re confiné tout un pays
est-ce qu'on va prendre des mesures qui
vont faire qu économiquement le pays
avoir beaucoup de mal à s'en remettre et
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui vont
être dans une détresse dans une
précarité dans une dans une détresse
psychologique incroyable pour un nombre
de morts qui n'est pour vous pas assez
important c'est ce que vous êtes grandir
je dis pas comme ça mais si on va dans
ce sujet là on va donner quelques
chiffres je n'aime pas beaucoup les
chiffres mais là ces signifiants
l'espérance de vie en france pour les
hommes elle est de 79 5
oui pour les femmes 85 et demi 83e 85e
dernière l'âge médian auquel on décède
du coc vide ses 85 ans oui
avec 65% de facteurs de comorbidité être
technique ça veut dire des maladies
cardiovasculaires et quand on arrive à
85 ans moi j'ai un père qui a 87 ans une
mère cac 79 ans on a des panneaux
avaient peur pour eux mais bien sûr que
j'ai peur je suis quoi un robot non mais
c'est sûr donc j'essaie d'être
raisonnable et je me prive d'aller les
voir comme beaucoup de français
bon je dis simplement aujourd'hui on
meurt
l'âge médian 85 ans avec deux tiers de
facteurs de comorbidité du diabète des
maladies cardiovasculaires des dde
on a fait les avc des insuffisances
rénales et c'est bon c'est ça la réalité
donc en fait on sait qu'aux vieillissent
aujourd'hui à pas grand-chose de l'on
sait que ce virus s'attaque didier
personnes les plus faibles
et puis je voulais pas dire on va
l'excellent griffier saison mais je vous
dis et je finis la fin ah oui vous allez
sortir vos parents la logique je vais au
bout de ma logique c'est pas le paquet
doit être mis sur ces personnes là oui
et c'est ce qui a commencé à être fait à
l'élaboration beaucoup de cafouillage
très 100% et qui mêlant 100% des efforts
doivent être faits sur nos anciens et il
faut arrêter de d'emmerder les français
oui les gens qui sont comme vous savez
une trente ans dans ce pays donc à 99
99% des cas vous allez avoir trois jours
de fièvre mondiale est me disait être un
peu malade je suis je résume ce que vous
dites mais oui je résume ce que vous
dites à à vous pour vous il faudrait
confiner les personnes les plus en
danger
les plus âgés et laisser vivre les
autres leur vie tranquillement et donc
en ce moment ce coupé peut-être de ses
grands-parents de ses parents comme vous
n'avez pas vous donc pour l'instant
c'est à dire juste les restes et les
laisser confiner ces personnes là et
essayer de les soigner peut-être par la
vaccination
c'est de les faire vacciner et laisser
les autres vivre normalement c'est ça
c'est peut-être pas très populaire ce
que je vous dis mais c'est votre
solution si on veut soigner les
populations à risque les populations les
plus fragiles celles dont on sait que
elles vont décéder en priorité 93 % des
plus de 105 ans décèdent du coc vide
c'est pas les jeunes qui meurent du coup
vous vous dites c'est ce que je fais ce
que voulait le virer deux variantes ou
le 10 % des jeunes ne savent pas dire tu
me choque énormément dans votre discours
j'ai l'impression d'entendre un discours
d'il ya trois ou quatre mois parce que
in motion dont vous ne parlez absolument
pas dans vos discours c'est la mutation
de ce virus celui qu'on a aujourd'hui
qui se multipliaient se démultiplient
c'est déjà plus la situation alors en
quatre mois mais justement justement ce
qui galope
justement si chaque fois qu'on re
confine si vous voulez on peut durer
mille ans à faire du stop and go on re
confine le virus a muté à baisser la
variante sud-africaine a c'est la
variante britannique assez le virus
saisonnier ac l'été à vous avez fait la
fête c'est l'hiver on va vous re confiné
nom peut aller comme ça de charybde en
scylla pendant 1000 au max un tous les
trois mois les vaccins alors les vaccins
il faut être extrêmement modeste je suis
pas du tout anti va je suis vacciné je
suis motard je suis tombé j'ai figures
antiques se faire vacciner
je suis à jour alors je vais attendre un
petit peu les fêtes je ne suis pas
prioritaire mes parents ils ont leur
libre arbitre et c'est eux qui
déciderait pour et vous vous êtes faut
je suis pour qu'il soit éclairé mon père
ne fera que compte la phrase il fera le
choix qui est le sien ma mère fera le
choix d'y aller parce que c'est alors
vous n'allez pas les pousser jamais je
ne les pousserait d'accord à faire et je
pense qu'il faut un libre consentement
de la personne va pas obliger les gens
se faire vacciner
ok il faut les aider il faut les
informer des pros contre le vaccin voilà
je suis ni pour ni contre
alors quoi ni pour ni conserver si vous
voulez ou pas alors j'ai tord ou de la
polio attendait en six ans
oui on ne croit pas à la science est le
contraire de la croyance
si vous me dites je crois je peux croire
en dieu je peux ne pas y croire
la science je veux voir des faits et je
veux avoir suffisamment de recul je suis
pas anti vax mai mais pour l'instant non
je n'ai jamais entendu j'ai entendu vous
parliez tout à l'heure du dr house
vous parliez d'un certain nombre de
sommités du monde médical
on a vu quand même des débats qui nous
ont tous interpellés
avec pas n'importe qui c'était pas le le
petit infirmiers de quartier qui dit oh
moi je suis contre les vaccins
c'était descend vite et d'avoir son avis
aussi je dis ça voilà je veux dire par
là c'est sur le mythe la n 1 mondiale
parce que epidemiol des épidémiologistes
facebook ou de renault qui vous disent
attention bon mais donc on n'a pas de
suffisamment de recul sur ses vaccins et
pour autant il faut pas être confinée
heureusement il ya des nids d'autres
vaccins qui arrive
il ya différents produits qui arrivent
il ya des demandes d'autorisation il va
dire qu'on va varier les sources
j'écoutais avant-hier c'était sur france
info la présidente deux ans info france
inter la première radio de france
voilà sa haute autorité de santé qui
était extrêmement modestes et qui disait
par exemple sur le passeport vaccin-là
on sait pas comment on ne sait même pas
si on étend vacciner on ne va pas être
transmetteur on sait pas combien de
francs vasseur vacciner une fois par an
deux fois par an sont peut-être plus
donc attendant d'avoir un petit peu de
recul je suis moi je suis ni contre ni
pour ceux ci pour le libre consentement
des personnes mais vous appelez les gens
quand même à aller faire un large appel
personne si je reste je m'en vais je
fais alors d'abrutis raymond répond avec
ma tête d'abruti si je vous écoute
parler vous voulez qu'on le coince
crever les lieux vous mangez du concile
mais si mais si vous aviez j'ai dit le
contraire on ne sait pas ce qu'il a dit
pattinson et j'ai dit le contraire il
veut pas se faire vacciner des contrats
gagnés pour confiner les personnes ne
veut pas se faire vacciner laisse
d'abord les autres faire pour voir ce
que ça fait mais par contre il veut je
suis monsieur c'est la désobéissance
avec ma tête d'abruti ça veut dire que
vous allez dire au genre alesi sortait
fait la fête vous êtes-vous travaillant
l'animation non vous êtes pompiers non
c'est vous qui allez allez d'aller dans
la rue en tant que policier pour faire
régner leur nom
quand vous dites je vais sortir moi je
vais je vais assumer vous allez sortir
vous allez aller ou si tout est fermé
vous avez ou dans la rue pour prendre
135 euros vous avez les moyens payés
tant mieux pour vous mais les mecs en
costard qui viennent nous expliquer
qu'ils vont désobéir d'où vous avez vous
pourquoi vous dites sans jean faut pas
dire aux gens qu'ils sont torturés dans
leur tête en ce moment qui sont en
galère qui sont qui savent pas où ils
sont qui croit plus en ce qu'on leur dit
à la télé qu'ils croient plus au
gouvernement qui croit plus les voleurs
de quoi et vous allez-vous vous leur
dites oh mais moi je vais désobéir la
marche pas c'est vous qui allez allez
devant lé sénat d'abord outre est comme
ça chez vous en costard et vous allez
regarder à bfm et fort je suis pas ce
qui se passe des fmg de regarder aussi
celles aussi mais voudrait vous vacciner
déjà non allez vous parler dans les
éviers vous allez par les trois quarts
d'heure bah écoute au tournant à
l'écouter c'est peut-être que j'étais
chose à dire quand même clamé tout ce
qui vous dit mes forces à venir jusqu'au
finalement pas grand chose si vous
voulez tellement qu'on m'a nommé vous
dit c'est vous même c'est vous même qui
vous qualifiez les rats mais pour des
abrutis et non mais oui vous dites le
contraire de ce que je dis c'est où je
dis qu'il faut soigner en priorité mais
personnes âgées d'accord sa corsa
d'accord est ce que vous allez vous
vacciner
je ne suis pas priorité cobayes non vous
le vaccin bail je ne suis pas
prioritaire
j'ai encore mon libre consentement oui
ça y est ma personne ne me fera vaccin
ya pas de problème d'accord en métal
dans là dessus mais vous en tant que
plus grand patron d'une grande radio qui
s'appuie sur à 4 ans et j'aimerais bien
dire aux gens à les y développe une fois
je dirai pas ce cas c'est pas vous qui
êtes devant les crs qu'allez-vous faire
frapper contre moi j'étais pendant deux
ans je m'ennuie et frappés dans leur rue
j'étais pas en costard mais oui ils ont
toujours été sur les toits j'ai du mal
avec les jours a pas ou qu'est ce qu'on
veut c'est que les gens des gens qui
appellent à la désobéissance et jolie
soit des des zombies c'est ce qui est
marqué la gms skis marquée là j'en sais
rien pas que vous étiez vous avez à dire
la radio ce que je ferai je ne dis pas
fait tout dans cette tombe jamais dans
la caricature
ça vous pouvez répéter une bêtise mille
fois ça sera toujours une bêtise mais ce
sera moi vous êtes vous savez si vous
avez assumé ce que je vais vous dire
simplement moins je dis que je ne me
reconsidérait pas je n'ai pas envie de
vivre sous cloche c'est vous qui payez
les français 84%
c'est vous qui les saignées ou c'est moi
que je paye c'est vous qui les pays
c'est moi qui paye les raser comme nous
par le biais de vous parce que moi tous
les jours et je me lève même et je vais
chercher ma pitance
mais moi aussi nommé ben voilà c'est le
sol et donc année
efforts collectifs à faire je dis
simplement qu'on est dans une mauvaise
séquence et que si on continue à se
confiner avec des stop and go on peut
vivre jusqu'à la fin des temps
honnêtement on est fatigué mais on ne
sait pas grand-chose mais faut mener une
chose et elle est évidente c'est que
s'il est à l'étape des mercantis décès
dans le monde entier s'ils font ça c'est
mazères par plaisir de dépenser des
milliards et des milliards de milliards
et que quelque part soit effectivement
c'est extrêmement dangereux et ils n'ont
pas osé veulent pas le dire je vois pas
pourquoi le monde entier la chine
angleterre les abonnés les anglais qui
sont qui sont un pays on peut pas pu me
faire le plus libéral que des anglais
les américains
tout le monde est satisfait et vous
écoutez madame écoutez moi également je
ferai donc je pense sincèrement que si
le monde entier fait l'effort qu'il faut
en train de faire a dépensé des
milliards pour soutenir tout le monde il
dépend ils se sont endettés à 133 des pb
vous pensez vraiment que c'est parce que
le virus il n'est pas dangereux il ya
forcément un danger pour nous et pour la
population y compris les contrats d'idée
si je vous suis benjamin ça veut dire
que la politique du brésil des états
unis de la chine de la corée du sud de
la corée du nord de l'italie de la
france l'allemagne la suède et du
danemark et de l'allemagne sont
identiques
non pas tout à bagram non c'est pas
identiques en tous cas pas les étonnés
c'est à des moments différents
l'exonération 4 millions par jour en
amérique
y'a pas et a pas beaucoup de regarder la
suède ils ont pris ils ont pris le parti
de laisser tout le monde dehors mais
séance ont conclu les uns parce que ça
n'a pas marché cyril c'est ce que je dis
ils ont pris dans ce débat raté c'est
qu'on est des croyances oui moi j'ai
commencé on dit j'ai pas de croyance
je suis pragmatique et je dis simplement
il faut être modeste personne n'a trouvé
la martingale personne n'a trouvé la
solution il faut laisser travailler
la science est peut-être faire oui faire
un peu preuve de modestie de la part des
voûtes des pouvoirs publics qui ont dit
les masses qui aura pas de problème
ou on est prêts on n'était pas prêts on
a cafouillé sans arrêt et c'est vous la
vérité dit que tout c'est que
c'est qu'on n'a aucune solution
scientifique à ce jour et que
aujourd'hui encore aussi on re confine
le remède sera pire que le mal d'un
point de vue sanitaire culturel social
et colonel fait moi je pense que de
façon si on re confine si on ne le fait
pas de la même manière que le premier ça
ne sert à rien quand on allait faire nos
courses on mettait même des gants on se
lavait avant les gants les mains après
les gants voilà si on fait un
confinement comme le deuxième ça ne sert
à rien et puis aussi dire que moi je
comprends ce que vous dites dans le
bénéfice risque puisque quelque part on
parle que des morts duo kobe mais on
parle pas à tout la grande partie des
français qui vivent vote ait eu son bord
de la mort mort économique en congé même
pendant les onze j'espère qu'on pourra
parler soir avec les les lycéens voilà
les jeux la jeunesse il on les invitera
demain bien entendu mais j'espère qu'on
va pas en parler parce que il ya
vraiment des situations incroyables il
faudrait vraiment qu'on fasse un gros
sujet là dessus j'espère qu'on pourra le
faire ce soir sinon le fera bien entendu
demain oui c'est pas du tout à
l'économie contre la santé 1 c'est pas
du tout ça que je dis et je dis les gens
qui concrètement moeurs
psychologiquement ou physiquement dû au
fait que tout est fermé tout est bloqué
et qu' ils ne peuvent plus vivre comme
ça donc mois le bénéfice risque quelque
part je l'entends alors guillaud moi je
suis désolé mais les questions que pose
didier elles sont légitimes
on est confiné le confinement certes il
fait baisser le nombre de cas mais il
n'a jamais irait éradiquer l'épidémie on
n'a pas de visibilité on sait pas
jusqu'à quand ça va durer ce que dit et
dit c'est qu'on a l'impression que ça va
durer jusqu'à la fin des temps et la
raison ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire on
est confiné cinq ans et dans cinq ans on
va nous dire en fait c'est une variante
moldaves du virus donc faut être confiné
c'est sans feindre n'a pas de visibilité
donc moi je rejoins toutes les questions
qu'ils posent sont légitimes
jamais sauf que moi je comprends votre
exaspération je comprends voilà tout
évidemment votre fatigue on l'a tous les
injonctions contradictoires
on les a toutes prises en pleine gueule
je comprends les les errements de la
vaccination effectivement rien n'est
crédible donc ça tout ça moi je
comprends mais ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est qu'en fait et ce qui
est très concret c'est dans les
réanimations et si mes parents et je ne
le serai pas à trappes locaux vides et
que les animations sont exempts de son
plein à craquer on vous dit mais
monsieur excusez-nous vos parents sont
propagées à ceusses qui sait ce qui se
passe dans pas mal desservi les
radiations et on va trier parce que vos
parents excusez moi ils ont moins
d'espérance de vie qu'un mec de 50 ans
45 ans vous direz quoi ce moment là
alors justement est ce que c'est ça
enfin clos mais c'est exactement ce que
j'essaie donc
au départ si vous voulez on est en train
de culpabiliser les français leur dire
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites sortir
vous appelait à la rébellion alors que
c'est pas du tout le cas
il met jamais en parler de milliards
dépensés effectivement il ya des
milliards qui sont dépenser des
centaines de milliards centaines de
milliards que sais tu combien de lits on
a créé en réanimation
on est à un an de cette de cette crise
est plus une crise puisque maintenant
c'est complètement installé dans la
population française est ce qu'on a créé
des liens vous avez raison est-ce qu'on
est en capacité est ce que le privé et
le public et ça c'est la vie ne serait
pas de solution vous dit qu'on est pas
on n'est pas équipé
ça fait vraiment rien dire un truc
vraiment je voulais dire un truc vite
fait qu'est-ce que vous répondez sans je
vais redescendre calmement je travaille
niall o pouey d'absurde et du bio mais
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gens moi
je savais c'est un truc qui m'a meurtrie
on sait pas ce que c'est ce qu'on vise
on dit que maintenant il attaque les
enfants de moins de dix ans et on dit
qu'à une variante qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qu'on enterrait des
gens dans un entrepôt à rungis à cause
du taux d'uc au vide ils n'ont pas eu
d'enterrement rien on les a mis dans des
boîtes à rungis dans des congélateurs
mais si vous voulez qu'on recommence
encore ça mais puisqu'il faut vous
prendre une décision qui est mondiale
mais on n'est pas que nous d'accord mais
on aurait la solution moi je ne veux pas
qu'on m'appelle de membre 10 ans ton
papa elle dans une boîte à rungis
qu'est-ce qu'il raymond et des morts et
dans un entrepôt d tous tu as fait quoi
et je m'en allais tous d'accord là les
chemins mais elle coûtera quand on est
tous d'accord là dessus si on était si
on était absolue mais moi le premier
mais tous les français si on était
absolument sûr et certain qu'en avançant
le couvrir ce cancer confinant bercero
on sert confine tant pis on va on va
finir exemple on va finir ruiner on va
protéger nos parents mais on n'a même
pas cette assurance
on n'a même pas cette association a
confiné en mars avril monsieur a pris y
avait plus d'entrer dans les animations
n'ont alors attendez quand on a confiné
en mars avril en version ferment alors
attention ferme
il ya eu une baisse de la pollution
hospitalière c'était en moins dans les
mailles mais cela en moi et c'est donc
alors donc donc on sait pas s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît à moi je voudrais
revenir sur un truc vous avez appelé
enfin vous avez dit que vous n'aviez pas
respecté un confinement s'il y en a qui
a annoncé la prochainement
il y en ad'autres autour de cette table
qui sont capables comme dire qu'ils
n'ont pas le respect répondait tout ça
c'est important ça c'est un truc parlons
aujourd'hui de savoir et répondez aux
nettement note guillaume
ah oui pardon mais psychologiquement
c'est un raid en vous je suis d'accord
avec lui et je respecterais pas parce
que psychologiquement c'est un enfer
d'être confiné tous les jours cyril on
reçoit dans cette émission des gens qui
sont doux de leur vie justement demain
demain on aura nos deux études avec nous
à un suicide burnout précarité on va en
parler demain avec que je sais faire un
gros truc sur et qu'on n'aura pas livré
des conséquences financières tout à
l'heure mais pardon mais les
conséquences psychologiques et pour tout
le monde pour nous tous elles sont
terribles
donc vous douzaine d'accords vous allez
bien sûr je suis d'accord depuis le en
plus il n'avait pas respecté le
confinement non il le dit de manière
veut il le dit de manière non-violente
il le dit de manière réfléchie donc
arrêté lui est tombé dessus comme ça et
là il a le droit d'avoir son avis sur la
situation et ça c'est le jeu hein
les connaissez le jour j'ai vu conduire
pour tout le monde donc vous vous allez
vous vous allez vous allez ne pas
respecter elle confierait pas non si je
suis sur vidal travail parce que vous
vous repère tout si j'allais travailler
au bureau j'ai travaillé au bureau si
j'ai envie de me balader je me baladais
non je vais pas aller faire la fête je
pète en boîte de nuit d'ailleurs elle
n'a pas même génial à regarder vous
allez respecter ou pas fermée - oui je
vais le respecter je suis pas
spécialement d'accord avec monsieur mais
par contre je peux facilement comprendre
c'est une philosophie de vie à chacun
qui voit la vie d'une manière différente
et moi je pense avoir bien compris quand
même que c'est en gros ce au modo c'est
laisser les gens un peu l'attraper et
advienne que pourra c'est un peu ça
quand même mais oui mais c'est ma
philosophie joe diop personnes
si ces personnes elles sont porteuses du
virus
yat-il bourrec mais là on est sur un
point clé cyril oui mais si si elle peut
contaminer d'autres personnes fragile
c'est pour ça court on est amis on est
sur un point clé je vous ai dit que
quand on se reconfigurer les clusters
surtout quand il fait la médaille c'est
à la maison et c'est bon s'il ya des
portiques des entrées et des sorties des
plexiglas comme on le fait dans le aux
médias oui si on peut on peut parler
vrai dire on a tous testés on se lave
les mre ouais donc ça il faut le
marteler de l'hygiène donc les cheveux
l'arrière et les gestes barrière de la
distorsion fait pas la fête comme des
idiots n'importe comment les gestes
barrière ça suffirait mais on fait ce
rêve ne suffira pas mais c'est de la
responsabilité personnelle et collective
c'est ça qu'il faut faire parce que le
confinement aujourd'hui on a
ça va baisser effectivement la pression
sur les hôpitaux de manière d'ailleurs
dont on pourrait débattre parce que avec
les variantes c'est en fait on ne sait
pas grand chose sur ce virus a et chaque
fois qu'on a des stratégies ondimba il
est malin il est plus intelligent et
sait donc que pardon et à la demande du
temps aussi quand on vous dit pendant
deux mois vous respecter des mesures
extrêmes hockey et dans deux mois vous
vous en êtes sortis
le problème c'est que c'est sans fin on
sait pas convaincant quand ça va finir
grainville le temps ils passèrent que
deux ans imaginons que ça dure deux ans
trois ans trois ans dans une vie c'est
énorme trois ans s'en sortir sans voir
ses amis s'en aller au restaurant son
travail et maintenant les normes ccc les
affaires mais le vaccin c'est alors non
nous avait parlé de modestie mais parle
en ayant la modestie justement de
reconnaître que si on n'a pas de
certitudes c'est parce qu'on avait une
situation inédite dans le monde bien sûr
et donc on doit sacrifier tout mais moi
je trouve que au contraire
évidemment vu quand on attend on trouve
ça toujours trop long mais mettre au
vaccin un vaccin au point à la vitesse à
laquelle on l'a fait ça n'est pas c'est
quand même positif mais bon je ne vais
pas dire que chacun fasse ce qu'il veut
c'est pas possible alors il faut pas les
abel il faut pas caricaturer
je n'ai pas dis chacun fait ce qu'il
veut j'ai dit simplement mettons nos
espoirs dans la science et je suis
heureux qu'ils aient d'autres et comme
beaucoup de gens nous pour l'instant le
pacs a voulu faire ça va sans dire pour
l'instant si vous voulez à son abdomen
j'y peux dire j'ai écouté vous avez un
président hu est possible à toute
autorité de santé
on lui posait la question sur les
passeports le passeport vaccinale et
c'est pour voyager pour aller au théâtre
pour aller au restaurant le disait mais
ça n'a pas de sens d'avoir un passeport
vaccinale au stade ou de nos
connaissances qui évolue tous les jours
puisqu'on ne sait même pas si avec ce
vaccin ne sera pas contagieux pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien donc
attendons ayons un recul nécessaire
c'est pour çà attendons qu'ils que des
je parle que la science devient quoi et
qui est des études indépendantes
parce que pour l'instant déjà le cas il
y en a eu quelques-unes
oui dans canal tels que jules il ya
beaucoup de communiqués de presse des
laboratoires did you need is temps et
parce qu'on est très en retard juste
nicolas et après je voudrais poser une
dernière question dîner très vite cyril
vous le savez parfaitement moi j'ai
passé du temps comme vous dans les
hôpitaux
ces dernières semaines est-ce que vous
avez vu l'état de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
dramatique la bd c'est dramatique pour
et des gens qui sont déjà à bout des
gens qui ont été obligés
des gens des infirmières de 23 24 ans
qui ont été obligés de faire des choix
et de dire ah bon le monsieur là vous le
laisser de côté ses 50 ans que ça donc
il n'était pas ça mais comment on peut
tenir ce genre de propos vous êtes en
train de vous voyez de vous perdre
didier qu'est ce qui vous arrive vous
pouvez pas mais moi j'ai dit je disais
téléspectateurs tiens voici exactement
le contraire un oui à 42% cours n'ont
atteint 58 ans dont 42 pour cent des
gens qui sont quand même d'accord avec
vous donc c'est ça c'est important quand
même d'accord avec guillaume l'assemblée
jean croit mer des antilles en dépit
cyril de la politique anxiogène de la
peur au fait régner parce que rappelez
vous de monsieur salomon qui tous les
jours veulent exercer pour toi la reine
non mais françois 42% de jean déchet
énorme
c'est énorme merci de vous y rendre
compte de sa merci didier